Steve Bannon is now going after me on
his program let me give you the back
story about this we did a segment
um a couple of weeks ago I guess it was
about an actual crazy person as I
described her going on Steve bannon's
program
and talking about all of the horrible
things that the satanic temple is doing
now as I've talked to you before the
satanic temple is not a scary
organization the satanic temple is no
less valid than any other religion first
and foremost and it turns out that the
person uh fear-mongering about the
satanic temple on Steve bannon's show
was actually a sister Mary Beth Bannon
and uh Steve Bannon seems to be
increasingly obsessed with the satanic
temple stuff but he now has gone after
me so here's the start of a clip from I
guess this was uh three days ago on his
show he interviews some guy about the
satanic temple stuff and then you'll see
that they cut to my segment about this
okay here's just a few seconds isn't the
issue you got these parents and it just
takes a couple kiss because the way
they're selling it we played the jingles
on uh and showed the videos on Saturday
I think my sister was here she she
brought up because a lot of people she
knows word about this right they make it
into self-empowerment so that segment in
which he brought his sister on is this
segment that we critiqued so then as you
can see he actually plays my segment and
we're going to go to the end of it
you've already seen my segment and it's
available I don't think we actually need
to play the whole thing but here's the
end of it and then it goes into Bannon
attacking me take a look clear that
there are certain things that it's not
just the difference of opinion it's not
it's it's something much more pernicious
and more than that okay we're gonna
that's that's brother that's brother
Dave Pacman uh he's got a show true
that's his analysis and we're doing this
as a teaching exercise many of you
remember that interview
from a couple of weeks ago but we also
played the Liberty Council who came on
afterwards and and talked about
everybody's very worried about the
satanic temple this is a real thing it's
not mental but you see how the left
what they want to do immediately
they don't want to dress they never want
to talk about what the thing is now
unfortunately for Steve we've talked
about what the thing is many times we've
interviewed Lucian Graves from the
Satanic Temple at least once now I don't
know if it's once or twice it's been a
while that we've been doing interviews
uh we have gone into detail about the
ways in which the satanic temple
Compares and contrasts to other
religions we've talked about the
principles of the satanic temple we have
talked about the thing
Steve Bannon doesn't want you to know
that or doesn't know that himself I want
to talk about what the issue is they all
they always want to um uh do an end
around or do a a uh a uh something to
Take Your Eye Off the Ball oh right
we're not going to fall for that oh
we know that the satanic clubs and the
Liberty Council has a different
Viewpoint that made the parents that are
in these school systems have okay all
right so anyway listen uh Steve Bannon
is welcome on this program quite
literally anytime I'm not super
interested in talking with him about the
satanic temple but I guess if that's
what it takes to get him on I'm willing
to willing to do it there are many other
things I would like to talk to Steve
Bannon about including his role in
bringing forward one of the most
disastrous presidencies in the history
of the United States certainly in the
last 50 years he's welcome on the
program quite literally Anytime by now
all of us know how creepy it is to talk
to a friend about something and then get
ads that are related when you use a free
email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend start
mail the email service that never scans
or analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out out your real email
address this protects you from spam and
phishing attacks phishing attacks are
becoming way more sophisticated with the
rise of chat GPT by the way start mail
lets you encrypt any email you send even
if the recipient isn't using encryption
unlike the big Tech email Services who
store even your deleted emails when you
delete an email in start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below